ينضم الي الان من لندن توبي كادمان
المحامي المختص بالقانون الدولي اهلا بك
معنا سيد توبي حدثنا عن تفاصيل
الاجراءات التي ستتبع لدراسه هذه الشكاوى
الجنائيه التي قدمت بحق الرئيس
الاسرائيلي شكرا اذا ما استمعنا اليه من
مكتب المدعي العام السويسري اولا هو ان
مكتب المدعي العام سوف ينظر في مساله
اسقاط الحصانه عن الرئيس الاسرائيلي للنظر
فيما اذا كان بالمستطاع ان يمضي قدما في
مسار النظر بهذه الشكوى بالنسبه الى مساله
الحصانه اذا ما قرر مكتب المدعي العام انه
لا يمكن الرئيس الاسرائيلي ان يعتمد على
الحصانه تمضي القضيه قدما اما اذا ما بقيت
الحصانه سوف تسقط القضيه وما من اجراءات
اضافيه تتخذ هذه الخطوه الاولى طبعا لا
يمكننا ان نعرف ما الذي سوف يحصل الا بعد
اتخاذ القرار بالنسبه الى هذه الخطوه
الاولى ضمن اي اطار زمني سيتم تحديد ما ان
سيرفع الحصانه عن الرئيس الاسرائيلي خاصه
ان بامكانه ربما المغادره
الان في الحقيقه عنما كنت اود ان اشكك او
اكون مشككا اذا اقول ان مكتب المدع العام
سوف يتخذ فتره اطول تسمح للرئيس
الاسرائيلي بان يغادر الاراضي السويسريه
لسوء الحظ على الارجح هذا ما سوف يحصل
طبعا مكتب المدعي العام يمكن ان يقرر انه
وبناء على فداحه الاتهامات وبناء على
الوري الرئيس الاسرائيلي وخصوصه التصريحات
التي ادلى بها الرئيس الاسرائيلي في هذا
السياق ان تهمه التحريض يمكن ان تتضمن في
هذه الشكوى لانه وقع القنابل التي قصف من
خلالها الجيش
الاسرائيلي قطاع غزه اذا هذا طبعا فعل
تحريضي اذا ما اراد المدع العام ان يمضيه
قدما سوف يتحرك بشكل سريع بشكل يمنع
الرئيس من المغادر ولكن معظم ذلك سوف
يعتمد على مستوى التدخل السياسي في هذه
المساله الذي قد لا يسمح لمكتب المدعي
العام ان يتصرف بشكل مستقل سيد طوبي
لنفترض جدلا ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي غادر هل
بامكان الادعاء العام
السويسري استدعائه والزامه بهذا
الاجراء تكيد هناك احتمال بان يحصل ذلك
ولكن السؤال يبقى ما اذا كان مكتب المدعي
العام سوف ياخذ بعين الاعتبار
ان الاجراءات يجب ان تتخذ في البلدان
الاخرى اي ان اسرائيل لا تسلم عاده
المطلوبين وبالتالي هذه مساله شائكه وهذا
يؤثر على مدى القدره على المضي قدما طبعا
يمكن الادعاء السويسري ان يطلب
تسليم المدعى عليه ولكن على اي حال الان
هو متواجد في دافس في الاراضي السويسريه
وبالتالي يجب ان يبذل مكتب المدعي العام
السويسري كل الجهود من اجل منع رئيسي من
المغادره في حال لم يتم اسقاط الحصان او
في حال تم اسقاط الحصانه برايك هل تتوفر
الظروف الكافيه ل تثبيت لاثبات هذه
الشكاوى الجنائيه التي قدمت بحق هرتسوغ
وفق طبعا من
قدمها في الحقيقه يتعين علينا ان نعاين
هذا الموضوع بشكل حذر بالنسبه الى دور
الرئيس الاسرائيلي ما هو الور الرئيس
الاسرائيلي وهل يتحمل مسؤوليه جنائيه بسبب
افعال دوله اسرائيل طبعا يمكننا ان نعود
الى تصريحاته التي عبر من خلالها عن رايه
وساهمت في التحريض وطبعا هو مسؤول رفيع في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اي السلطه التنفيذيه
هو الرئيس لدوله اسرائيل وبالتالي لديه
مسؤوليه ولكن يبقى السؤال هل لديه قدره او
سلطه على اتخاذ القرار بالمقارنه مع وزير
الدفاع او رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي او
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الاسرائيليه هذا يبقى
السؤال المفتوح بالنسبه الى اي اتهامات
يجب ان تثبت ان الرئيس الاسرائيلي مشارك
لاننا نتحدث عن مسؤوليه جنائيه فرديه وليس
مسؤوليه جماعيه وبالتالي من الاهميه بمكان
ان يتم توثيق دور الرئيس الاسرائيلي وما
ان يتم تقديم الشكوى و اتخاذ القرار بشان
الشوى في بشان الشكوى في سويسرا نرى
النتيجه ولكن ما يمكننا ان نقول هو بشكل
واضح هو ان الادله واضحه
ودامغة تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار من ناحيه
السلوك الذي قام به الشخص الرئيس ام
سيحاسب بما قامت به دوله اسرائيل
المسؤولين في اسرائيل لو توضح لنا هذه
الجزئيه نعم بكل تاكيد في قضيه جنائيه
الشخص يكون مسؤولا عن افعاله الفرديه كفرد
كشخص
ومجددا هناك تهم توجه الى اشخاص وليس الى
دول وبالتالي مجموعه من المسؤولين ولكن
هذا الشخص هو يطلع بمسؤوليه رئاسه دوله
اسرائيل وبالتالي لديه مسؤوليه مرتبطه
بسلوك هذه الدوله ورايناه في السابق على
سبيل المثال في حاله سلوبودان ميلويفيتش
في الماضي بشان جرائم المرتكبه في البلقان
في التسعينيات من القرن الماضي وهو حوكمه
ليس لقاء جرائم ارتكبها ولكن كمسؤول الوله
لديه مسؤوليات في هذه الدوله طبعا يجب
اثبات ان هذا الشخص ضالع في عمليه اتخاذ
القرار في هذه الدوله ولكن ليس بالضروره
ان يرتكب الفعل بنفسه وبالتالي نعم يمكن
ان يحاسب ويحاكم بسبب توليه منصب رئاسه
اسرائيل نعم سيد طوبي لو سمحت ابقى معنا
ونود ان تستمع معنا الى ما يقوله الى هذا
المقطع للرئيس الاسرائيلي الذي تحدث به
امام منتدى دافوس حينما سئل عن مقتل عشرات
الاف المدنيين الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه
نستمع we care we
care pain
for neb so much but how else can we
defend ourselves he decided to entrench
themselves in an infrastructure of teror
unbelievable اذا سيد توبي استمعت معنا
لما قاله الرئيس الاسرائيلي
ما رايك ما رايك بما تفضل به خاصه انه
ناقد نفسه على ما يبدو قال نحن ربما
غير لا اخجل من التحدث عن مقتل عشرات
الالاف من المدنيين
الفلسطينيين
اعتقد ان هذا التصريح هو مهم لانه عبر عن
راي الرئيس الاسرائيلي بشكل متسق وايضا
راي مسؤولين اسرائيليين اخرين يتم التركيز
دائما على هجمات حماس في السابع من اكتوبر
والرد ايضا وهذه التصريحات يجب ان تؤخذ في
سياق الدعاء والتهمه الموجهه للرئيس طبعا
حصل في السابع من اكتوبر قد حصل ولكن يجب
النظر فيما حصل بعد السابع من اكتوبر بحق
المدنيين في معظمهم من النساء والاطفال
والذين قتلوا منذ السابع من اكتوبر
وبالتالي يجب ان يحاسب المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون ااء سلوكهم ولا يمكن ان يتم
التغاضي عن هذا الموضوع طبعا السلوك
الاسرائيلي هو يناقض القوانين الدوليه
ويجب ان يقي العقاب ااء ذلك يعني هل يمكن
القول ان حديثه عن عدم خجله في قتل عشرات
الالاف من المدنيين الفلسطينيين هذا
التصريح
يدينه في الحقيقه بالنسبه الى هذه
التصريحات هي تساهم في القضيه ضد الرئيس
عندما يضلي
بتصريحات مماثله انه لا يخجل اذا مقتل
اكثر من 20 الف مدني عندما تضاف هذه
التعليقات الى التعليقات الاخرى
والتصريحات الاخرى التي ادلى بها في
السابق هذا يعزز القضيه المرفوعه ضد
الرئيس شكرا جزيلا لك كنت معنا من لندن
توبي كادمن المحامي المختص بالقانون
الدولي